be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so as we continue
our discussion on Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four we pick up now with issue
number 574 and what I want to do at
least what I've done in the last video
is in the description I actually put a
reading list as well as a link to where
you can buy this on comiXology because
to be quite frank with you guys these
videos I think will be entertaining if
you haven't read the Fantastic Four from
Jonathan Hickman but it's also something
that I suggest you read on your own just
because you can do it a leisurely pace
and there'll be a couple things here and
there that I'll be required to pass over
but because the story is so good again
this is something I highly suggest you
guys buy but with this particular comic
we actually start out with the birthday
of Franklin Richards now this is why I
love Jonathan Hickman stories so much
because he doesn't forget the small
things and what I mean here is that with
the Fantastic Four be Marvel's original
superhero team they've been around for
decades and their stories have seen a
multitude of different things take place
they've done everything from fight
street-level heroes to take on Galactus
and deal with cosmic and even
multiversal level threats there was even
a story where the Fantastic Four went
beyond the multiverse and visited the
one above all which is a comic a lot of
people reference when they say that the
one above all is Jack Kirby
but with Jonathan Hickman he reminds us
that despite the fact that they've done
these incredible things they're still
human they're still on a basic level
people they have thoughts they have
feelings they have emotions they have
children to take care of and with
Franklin Richards this is especially
important and the reason why I think
this matters so much is with Franklin as
a character most anyone who's ever read
anything about Marvel Comics or has a
passing interest has looked at the
character of Franklin and been enamoured
by the powers that he possesses as a
child he's effectively able to control
the Marvel Universe depending on who you
talk to he's actually the reason why
characters don't age but with the
abilities that he displays is very easy
to look over the fact that he's still a
kid and so with this birthday issue what
we get is Valyria Richards giving
Franklin Richards a present but then
also revealing that this birthday party
is a surprise birthday party now again
with this whole celebration we see
mishmash of different characters show up
and what we don't need to go through all
of them some of the characters that seem
to appear here are both powerpack as
well as leech now with power pack for
those of you guys who don't know there
was a point in time where Marvel was
reaching out to the younger audience
space and I don't mean teenagers
actually mean little kids and what they
did is they created a superhero team
called power pack which included
Franklin Richards but also had various
other heroes involved now I've got a
video on power pack I believe that
you're welcome to check out and if I
have that video I'll post it in the
description but with the character of
leech in my mind I think he's actually
one of Marvel's most powerful mutants by
his very nature leech is what's called a
Morlock meaning he has a physical
deformity which keeps him from being
able to live on the surface and instead
he lives in the tunnels but the power of
leech is to actually shut off the powers
of other people and as far as we know in
Marvel Comics there's no limit to this
and so it could be that he could take on
apocalypse and somebody just shut off
apocalypses access to his powers of
immortality different things like that
he could take on someone with insane
abilities whether or not he could stop
gene gray from being the Phoenix it's
something we don't know and I don't
think that situations ever been explored
although I would be interested to see
that comic but leech is very formidable
just because of the fact that he can
turn off other people's abilities but in
addition to this and something that I
also like you guys take note of here is
Spider Man one of the funny gags with
this is that Ben Grimm basically
introduces all the children to Spider
Man and they react exactly the way we
would expect them to the kids say that's
not Spider Man you know and of course
the real Peter Parker shows up but the
reason why this matters is I would like
you to pay particular attention to how
Franklin Richards relates to Spider Man
because there is a beautifully written
issue later on in the story where
Franklin Richards spends time with
spider-man and we get some very in-depth
views into how Peter Parker views his
life after the death of Uncle Ben
but this relates to the fact that Johnny
Storm will actually die later on which
is kind of a spoiler here but that of
course takes place during the
annihilation storyline which again will
tie in here in a little bit but with
Franklin Richards spending time with
Spider Man they just kind of hang out
and there's really not a whole
a lot to go on here not a whole lot to
celebrate of course he takes him on a on
a ride through the town which happens
off panel we don't really see that but
was the two of them returned we see a
little bit of banter back and forth
between Peter Parker and Johnny Storm
and this again if those of you guys who
are currently reading the the spider-man
run is where a lot of this stuff hails
from even though they're not necessarily
the best of friends at this point in
time they are still extremely good
friends and so as we continue on with
our run of Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four with issue 574 we actually pick up
later on that night and this is where
the story gets cool what happens is
because the technology of the Fantastic
Four allows them to basically monitor
everything that goes on within and
without the Baxter building on a global
scale the building is met with a time
quake condition red now while hitman
doesn't tell us exactly what this means
we can basically just infer that
somebody's opening a portal somewhere
and indeed that's exactly what happens
but the individual that shows up
completely incapacitate the Fantastic
Four now while he doesn't necessarily
beat them he puts up a force field that
they can't get past and when I was
reading this I was like oh my god who is
this guy like what's going on here and
we don't find out and so later on but
what happens is while Susan storm tries
to get past this while Reed Richards
puts his mind to the test Ben Grimm
tries to pummel through it there's
nothing they can do but more notably
whenever they punch a hole through a
wall to try to get around it the force
field expands to fill that hole so
they're basically never ever going to
get through but from here we see
Franklin Richards as a child actually
sped out into the hallway trying to
figure out what's happening now again
one thing to keep in mind here is that
Franklin doesn't have powers he's just a
young kid he's just a boy and so while
the Fantastic Four call out to this guy
and try to get him to stop he murmurs
something to Franklin Richards and
effectively lifts him into the air now
from here the man goes into the bedroom
of Valyria Richards now again valaria is
a character who is wildly intelligent in
the realm of Marvel Comics in fact she
is right up there with Reed Richards and
dr. doom and it's probably one of these
smartest people probably the number one
smartest person on the planet when
everything is taken into account and in
fact during Hickman's run
of Secret Wars the valaria Richards was
the one that came to the conclusion that
the incursion cannot be stopped
Reed Richards didn't come to a
conclusion first it was actually her now
Reid of course he didn't want to listen
to it he wanted to reserve his reality
but at the end of it all he had to
accept her calculations as being
absolutely true but what this man says
to Valyria Richards is that the future
must be avoided at all costs now again
this is classic Jonathan Hickman this is
really just him telling us stuff and we
have no clue what's going on so if you
feel yourself being confused don't feel
bad it's the nature of pigment stories
but all of this will begin to make sense
as things go on now what he says to her
is that there will be a war between the
four cities and that those who died
cannot be forgotten now this is
something that I really want you to pay
attention to because the next thing he
tells her is that all hope lies with dr.
Guerin and this is the craziest thing
this is the craziest situation but again
all of this will be made to make sense
but when is it up happening is as he
begins to make his way out he begins to
lead valaria catches up with him and she
says happy birthday which tells us this
is the adult version of Franklin
Richards and so once everything begins
to calm down what's his version vanishes
and the portal disappears and Reed
Richards Ben Grimm Johnny Storm and
Susan storm get with the kids and they
basically put them back to bed the
conversation becomes who is that guy
and why was he able to shut everything
down now for here we also take note of
the fact the Valeri Richards has her own
little calculations on how to solve the
problem everything and while this isn't
very important right now this will be
very important later on but more notably
than this what we learn is that the
words that the adult Franklin Richards
muttered to his younger self was to rest
and remember who he was and this is why
I love the story so much I love this
comic because what's happened here is
the adult Franklin Richards has woken up
the powers of his younger self now will
actually learn later on that other
things are happening that he actually
mentioned other things to him and we'll
learn there's a lot more to the
situation than what's initially being
revealed to us
but because Franklin Richards powers
have been restored to him the first
thing he does is create a pocket
universe in the bedroom of his room now
how awesome is that
with that being said guys I really hope
you feel the excitement in this comic
because this is such a cool story and it
really only gets better from here it
just keeps going up and up and up and it
leads to this amazing finale but with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and if you
guys are enjoying this Hickman's
Fantastic Four drop a like in a comment
it's always a good thing if you guys do
that and I will catch you all later
peace